là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la france au fond des yeux ligne
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils apprennent à
tricoter d'accord à votre place je la
ramène un peu moins mais si vous ne
réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous manque
qu'une seule chose à tout petit détail
le trophée les valises à paris
qu'est ce qui lui arrive à la baule
comme chaque semaine france info et
l'ina vous offre un voyage dans le temps
à travers les archives de la télévision
pour décrypter l'actualité contemporaine
c'est l'inattendu et vous êtes les
bienvenus à mes côtés camille d'auxerre
et avec elles des journalistes à la
rédaction lina bonjour à tous les deux
alors vous camille vous avez choisi de
revenir sur la polémique qui concerne
l'unef syndicat étudiant qui organise
des réunions non oui exactement la
semaine dernière sa présidente mélanie
luce a défendu ses réunions non mixtes
au sein du syndicat qui permettrait aux
personnes victimes de discrimination de
s'exprimer a priori plus librement des
réunions notamment interdite aux blancs
ce qui déchaîne les passions
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer les a comparé à du
fascisme des élus demandent la
dissolution du syndicat étudiant sauf
que tous ont l'air de découvrir le
principe de ces réunions non mixtes or
ce n'est vraiment pas nouveau dans les
années 60 les noirs aux états unis avec
les black panthers s'organise et se
réunit ce sont les blancs leur fameux
slogan à l'époque bailleuse for us par
nous mêmes pour nous mêmes
autre exemple de non-mixité plus proche
de nous dans les années 70 en france
cette fois les féministes veulent rester
entre elles l'heure de la révolte contre
l'homme a sonné conséquence pas d'hommes
dans les réunions du mlf ou
exceptionnellement on aurait voulu c'est
que les mecs comprennent que leur place
n'était pas là dans ce premier temps de
lui
pour la libération des femmes la place
des mecs et à la crèche ou encore
et alors que leurs épouses discuter de
l'avortement libre et gratuit de la
contraception du viol de l'homosexualité
de l'accouchement il langer et pouponner
voilà la non-mixité ça date pas d'hier
merci beaucoup alors tu arrives où vous
avez choisi de revenir sur ce
documentaire qui qui fait beaucoup
réagir depuis quelques jours c'est de
moi de le dire je ne suis pas une c'est
là que je suis une journaliste signée
marie portolano et guillaume priou tout
est dans le titre
là oui c'est ça donc les ont recueilli
des témoignages de plusieurs concerts
journaliste sportive elle nous raconte
un peu à ces violences sexistes nous a
dit nasa nous a fait penser à une
archive alors elle montre pas tout à
fait ce qui est raconté dans le
documentaire mais elle en dit très long
sur le sort qui est réservé aux
journalistes sportifs veut on né en 1978
une petite nouvelle intègre l'équipe de
sport première c'est l'athlète marie
christine de bourse
championne de france de saut en hauteur
et voici comment elle nous est présenté
à son arrivée
marie-christine à l'origine c'était une
de ces très jolies filles comme il ya
l'attend dans le nord et dans le midi
aussi et à l'est et à l'ouest également
quand on n'est jamais trop prudent sur
ce plan-là je voudrions que toutes les
mères de famille il ya envoyant un
marketing de bourse sur ces photos et
c'est sur ces images et sur nos écrans
vite à leur fille si tu veux être aussi
belle que marie-christine plus tard
commence par faire d'une pomme pourrait
dire aussi à marc excessive de bourse
que l'intérêt des femmes pour le sport
est le meilleur moyen
poussez les garçons à battre des records
et la voix ces scènes de genre oui c'est
ça qui nous chuchoter l ébène belle donc
voilà on dit qu'elle est belle qu'elle
est jolie a oublié qu'elle est
journaliste et ancien athlète et que
tout ça d'un j'ai envie de l'écouter
pour ça en fait
voilà pour l'actualité de cette semaine
mais que s'est il passé le 24 mars à
travers le temps c'est le zapping de
l'ina et ça s'est passé à 24 mars
justement bonjour
radovan karadzic a été reconnu coupable
de génocide crimes contre l'humanité et
crimes de guerre
il est condamné à 40 ans de prison toute
cette poignée de main franco américaine
cell un accord original eurodisneyland
le parc d'attractions sera construit à
30 km à l'est de paris dans le secteur
de la ville nouvelle de marne la vallée
la compagnie disney qui financent
seulement 4 % du projet ne devrait pas
avoir trop de mal à convaincre d'autres
partenaires financiers pour boucler son
budget le premier coup de pioche est
prévu en 1988
c'est en s'engageant dans le détroit de
prince william que l'accident s'est
produit
pour éviter à bloc de glace comme celui
ci ce pétrolier de 300 mètres de long a
changé sa route mais il a heurté un
écueil une erreur de navigation qui a
coûté cher
quarante mille tonnes se sont échappés
des huit cuves percée formant une nappe
de 8 km qui a commencé à toucher les
côtes de l'alaska
michel debré à 76 ans il vient d'être
élu à l'académie française
un honneur pour l'île de la réunion dont
il est député
mon idéal à l'habitude de dire michel
debré aurait été d'être un écrivain
ironie du destin c'est un homme d'état
qui entrent sous la coupole
voici cinquante ans moore et amiens le
génial précurseur qui en haut de ce
pigeonnier écrivit la majeure partie de
ses livres dans lesquels par une
prescience jamais en défaut il prévu
l'essentiel des inventions que notre
siècle a vu se réaliser
bonsoir ya demain
[Musique]
ce week end dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche on va passer à l'heure d'été
alors on avance ou on recule sa montre
et bien on avance un concrètement à 2
heures du matin il sera 3 heures deux
fois par an c'est toujours la même chose
on change d'heure est à chaque fois
cabinet d on se demande si ça sert
encore à quelque chose
et à chaque fois on se dit c'est
vraiment un maronite comme il en était
quand même vous leur dites comme la
majorité des français nathanaël mais
c'est ce qu'on appelle donc un
marronnier dans notre milieu
journalistique deux fois par an pour
ceux qui ont une montre encore on la
remet à l'heure d'hiver heure d'été 45
ans que ça dure depuis 1976 et 45 ans de
débat de polémique commençait en faire
en france
donc cette fois ce soir eh ben on va
tenter de remettre les pendules à
l'heure il en rit
vous avez dit 21h50 pas plus je me
trompais acquis ce n'est jamais arrivé
oublié de remonter les aiguilles de sa
montre l'histoire commence qu'en 1973
choc pétrolier le prix du baril flambe
la chasse au gaspi et à l'économie
d'énergie est lancée en france pas de
pétrole mais on a des gîtes et la grande
idée du changement d'heure c'est valéry
giscard d'estaing qui la jec par exemple
que l'on fera en conduit à fixer une
heure de printemps une heure d'été pour
mieux faire coïncider le jour et la
journée
faire coïncider jour et journée pour -
allumer les lumières et donc économiser
de l'électricité
ça commence trois ans plus tard en 1976
nous y voilà
c'est cette nuit que nous commencerons à
économiser un peu plus d'énergie en
utilisant un peu mieux la lumière
solaire et le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que les français sont complètement
fou mais d'abord madame keller et s il
vous plaît en ce moment il est 11h -
sackey leur demain keller sera-t-il
sexuellement avec le changement
d'horaire consiste en quoi
quelles sont
vous ne savez pas qu'il ya un chargeur
ce soit des français perdus et en colère
au fil des ans les opposants à l'heure
d'été se font entendre des professeurs
des agriculteurs tous dénoncent se
dérègle mon général les reproches ne
manquent pas premier argument le sommeil
des enfants est perturbée alors en
classe ils dorment ils by moins
d'entrain moins de participation chez
les plus grands chez les agriculteurs
les deux heures d'avancé en été ne sont
pas tellement apprécié le soleil de
rythme plus de travail aux champs que le
tic tac de l'horloge pour les vaches
laitières seul et des règles
complètement
on a une perte de l'est les normes des
vaches déréglé mais loin des champs ou
défend l'heure d'été et ses soirées
lumineuse pour ou contre le débat
rejoint l'arène politique
en 90 ségolène royal rend un rapport
critique au ministre de l'industrie en
76 ça faisait des économies d'énergie
puisque ont apporté du fioul mais depuis
quatre cinq ans on sait très bien qu'il
ya plus d'économies de devises et donc
on aurait dû avoir le courage de
remettre ça en cause mais depuis on
consulte on fait des rapports et en 2019
l'europe
arbitre elle donne deux ans aux pays
membres pour décider quel fuseau horaire
adopté excusez-moi camille je compte sur
mes dames et si je compte bien 2019 plus
deux ans ça fait 2021
c'est donc la dernière fois qu'on change
d'heure alors vous comptez bien nathanel
mais non ce ne sera pas pour cette année
la dernière fois en fait on l'a dit dans
le sujet en 2019 l'europe se met
d'accord sur un point on arrête le
changement d'heure et elle donne deux
ans aux pays-bas pour s'accorder pour
dire bon bah choisissez soit le fuseau
de l'heure d'été soit celui de l'heure
d'hiver
il faut qu'on évite le patchwork en fait
deux fuseaux horaires au sein de l'union
européenne
ils ont choisi qu'au bas sauf que le coc
vide est passée par là forcément le
changement d'heure tout le monde en a
plus rien à faire ce n'est plus à
l'ordre du jour en europe et donc on
risque encore de changer d'air cet hiver
peut-être même en 2022 ou en 2023 en
france en tout cas c'est l'heure d'été
vous voyez la majorité des français
comme vous nathanel préfère ce créneau
ce fuseau horaire 59%
deux français ont dit de selon une étude
de l'assemblée nationale en 2019 qui
préférait ce fuseau l'allemagne aussi
penche du côté de l'heure d'été mais
mais les pays du nord avec nos voisins
néerlandais danois par exemple eux sont
pour l'heure d'hiver bref donc les pays
européens ont vraiment intérêt à
s'accorder pour éviter un cauchemar
logistique pensez simplement aux
travailleurs transmettre transmettra les
frontaliers il va falloir que c'est
impossible de changer de pays avec deux
fuseaux horaires différents ou bien
encore les trains qui traverse l'europe
il faut forcément qui traversent des
pays avec les même fuseau bref pléthore
d'exemples il faut que les pays
européens se mettent d'accord
on n'a pas fini d'en reparler non merci
beaucoup quand la télé se mobilisent
pour lutter contre le sida le sidaction
est organisé ce week end pour nous en
parler
une figure historique de ce marathon
télévisuel un acteur engagé dans la
lutte contre cette maladie regarde
montrer comme ça en gros plan un
préservatif à la télévision ça veut
quand même dire que nos moeurs ont bien
évolué et j'en suis ravi foot
bonjour christophe dechavanne j'avais
jamais vu ce team alpha sim non bonjour
l'inattendu est ravie de vous offrir ce
petit voyage dans le temps c'était en
1987 un début du combat un combat dans
lequel vous êtes largement investi 34
ans plus tard la mobilisation continue
la guerre n'est pas terminée
est ce que c'est une bonne ou une
mauvaise nouvelle dans la bonne nouvelle
quand même c'est que les tranchées sont
rampe moins rapidement et que donc le
sida est une maladie toujours aussi
toujours aussi grave toujours toujours
qu'on tractable sais pas si c'est
française que je dîne le même temps
voilà donc sinon facettes jaune maladie
de l'amour c'est toujours de maladies
sexuelles notamment
donc c'est toujours aussi importantes
sont protégés maintenant c'est passé
très emmerdant parce que la position de
lire on en meurt beaucoup moins c'est
beaucoup moins c'est vrai et en même
temps ça provoque forcément relâchement
donc on ne doit pas avoir ce relâchement
on en meurt toujours on en meurt
toujours mais beaucoup moins car grâce à
dieu la science a fait des progrès
extraordinaires et donc la trithérapie
où on mettait à 40 pilule
par jour il ya 20 ans est aujourd'hui
limité à deux ou trois mais avec des
effets secondaires donc je ne souhaite à
personne de vivre sous trithérapie par
exemple sous traitement alors christophe
vous avez présenté la toute première
émission du sidaction un tous contre le
sida s'est éteint en 1994 20 millions de
téléspectateurs à l'époque ah oui alors
j'en ai même été à l'initiative
ouais j'ai un peu la prétention je n'ai
pas dit pendant des années
et puis après tout alors justement
comment comment est-ce qu'on en est
arrivé à être à l'initiative
et bien parce que je m'occupais que
comme vous l'avez vu je m'occupais
depuis des années de la prévention avec
avec l'outil que j'avais entre les mains
sans mauvais jeu de mots qui était la
télé et donc depuis c'est encore mieux
l'après midi on a vu des images de deux
secondes et puis je suis allé voir tous
les patrons de chaînes en leur disant
voilà il ya un truc super grave ce qui
se passe grosso modo on ne fait pas ce
qu'il faut
la prise de conscience n'est pas la
bonne n'est pas assez forte et la guerre
des chaînes est telle que si un jour
vous vous unissez tous pour faire de la
première à la sixième
le même programme à la même heure toute
la nuit ma foi les gens vont dire il se
passe quelque chose et le fait de dire
il se passe quelque chose
alors peut-être que la prise de
conscience sera plus importante et au
début ça n'a pas été facile
et puis line renaud et monsieur bergé
ont pris le relais et ont le plus
d'influencé que moi et donc ça s'est
fait dans les semaines ou mois qui ont
suivi mais j'ai été je me souviens très
bien avoir patrick le lay nicolas de
tavernot et tous les patrons de chaînes
pour le dire unissez-vous et en 94 vous
avez récolté 300 millions de francs ça
fait à peu près 45 millions d'euros
alors chaque année le sidaction récolte
des fonds pour la recherche une
mobilisation riche en émotions et en
souvenirs tarek vous avez retrouvé
quelques temps forts de ce rendez vous
bah oui on n'a pas attendu c'était dès
la première émission que ce rendez-vous
nous a offert des petits moments de télé
comme ça donc 7 avril 1994 cette
première émission c'est déjà un
événement d'avoir toutes ces stars a
réuni sur ce plateau il y en a une qui
se démarque ce soir là c'est clémentine
célarié
on va regarder c'est un moment de télé
encore culte aujourd'hui le baiser le
serment demain etc etc on le répétera
jamais assez ne ne contamine pas plaisir
quelque chose que jouer enfin c'est une
bêtise c'est un truc bête que j'ai envie
de faire depuis
depuis le début parce que après tout on
est là pour s'unir les séropositifs les
pas séropositif les homosexuels et pour
homosexuels et j'ai envie de faire un
truc con mais j'ai envie d'embrasser le
monsieur qui est derrière moi sur la
bouche
voilà ce qu il a de la chance monsieur
un vrai et je suis sûr que dans trois
mois on aura toujours des quartiers
l'euro la démago et les ruines et tout
ça c'était juste une envie que je vais
pouvoir uniquement pour que tout le
monde comprenne enfin que je ne suis pas
contagieux je suis exigeante
éventuellement ces transmissibles vous
êtes à côté christophe dechavanne vous
souvenez forcément oui oui oui j'ai sage
et avancer les choses et des jaloux ça
c'est resté un symbole magnifique ça
veut dire que il y avait quand même des
idées reçues épouvantable qui traînait
de ci de là alors on va pas politiser
les choses mais les maladies
malheureusement l on voit aujourd'hui le
sont toujours donc c'est vrai que à
l'extrême droite le sida c'était la
maladie du diable c'est un mahdi des
homos des drogués et puis ça traînait un
peu partout ces rumeurs elle a prouvé
par ce baiser qu'on pouvait embrasser
tendrement à un homme séropositif qui va
d'ailleurs toujours très bien
aujourd'hui et ma foi
c'était une démonstration qu'il fallait
arrêter de dire ouh là là ça s'attrape
tiges bois dans le vert mon voisin enfin
il ya eu des catastrophes qu entraîner
comme ça pendant des mois ou des années
donc elle a évidemment clémentine avec
ce charme qu'on lui connaît participer à
rendre
on va dire un peu plus tolérable et
acceptables est plus approchable et les
autres plutôt que de rejeter cette
nouvelle grande mouvance de
communication oui oui parce que les
séropositifs étaient vraiment vu comme
comme comme comme des parias quoi il y
relate ce sujet je voudrais vous montrer
encore des archives
on va remonter assez toute cette période
dont vous parlez c'était il ya quarante
ans 1980 on découvre les premiers cas de
sida aux états unis 83 en france à
l'institut pasteur découvre le virus
responsable du sida et la télé vous dit
vous vous direz de mariée de madame
mariette initié voilà exactement et la
télé elle parlait forcément de tout ça
le parler du sida et je veux vous
montrez moi tu sais c'est préjugés qu'on
avait à l'époque un certain il mettait
beaucoup de psychose nous parle beaucoup
du sida
la peste gay qui s'étend sur notre pays
il ne se moque pas de dieu
tu as brisé toutes ces lois est lui dans
sa miséricorde de jugera pour cela je
crois que le sida x y ou les j'emploie
ce mot là cette année au logis du n'est
pas très beau mais je n'en connais pas
d'autre
celui là il faut bien le dire est
contagieux par sa transpiration ses
larmes ça salit le belge en montagne si
je détiens espèce de l'épreuve si j'y
vois là jean marie le guen vous nous en
parliez tout à l'heure et l'espèce oui
jean marie le pen vous en parlais tout à
l'heure mais voilà cette époque ça
montrait aussi que le sidaction c'est
aussi dédramatiser cette maladie ont
éclaté cet étang attisé et faire prendre
conscience ce genre aussi qu' il fallait
il fallait que tout le monde y est il
fallait que tout le monde participe
il fallait que que les chercheurs
étaient au taquet partout où ils le sont
toujours
ce que le vih est un virus un virus
costaud et compliqué mais voilà c'était
c'était oui c'était faire participer
tout le monde et montrer que tout le
monde était mobilisé 2 2 de toutes les
couches de tous les artistes de toutes
les tous les pays d'europe
enfin même pas un cadeau christophe pour
parler de l'actualité aujourd'hui qu'on
en 10 mois 11 mois on a trouvé un vaccin
contre le corps d'un virus
ce qui est extraordinaire en plus c'est
que le virus du code du virus
enfin ce corner aussi beaucoup ressemble
un peu à celui du vih et ça vous donne
quoi de l'espoir ou disant tiens ça va
peut-être les mettre sur la bonne piste
tous et toutes façons les galaxies
laissez pas frustrant aussi non non non
non non non de tout progrès de sion ce
n'est pas frustrant pour un autre donc
c'est formidable et puis je crois que
les moyens qui ont été mis en avant je
pense qu'ils doivent à peu près valoir
ce côté mais en 30 mai et en trente ans
les programmations soit extraordinaire
enfin tout le tout tout tout tout les
scientifiques ont bossé sur le sida oui
on fait des progrès absolument
extraordinaire vous avez dit tout à
l'heure on en aura encore je dirais
presque plus ouais on est traité on
reste séropositif mais il ya beaucoup je
n'ai pas les chiffres exacts je ne sais
pas si vous avez aimé les morts du sida
aujourd'hui sont très très faible par
rapport à l'époque oui c'est une
catastrophe planétaire est en tout cas
il faut rester
prudent alors juste un gros rester
vigilants et sans vous savez mais vous
avez mené un combat bien particulier
j'irai me dire avec le fameux sortez
couverts un lancier à la fin de vos
émissions
c'est devenu le nom de la marque de
préservatifs le préservatif à dire 1
euro 1 franc c'est ça il a dit s'être
senti donc oui mais vous rendez compte
qu'en même temps on va plus 20 ans on a
gardé exactement le même prix avec la
société polidis que je remercie parce
que ce sont mes vrais partenaires patrie
de pisa et bertrand et on a fabriqué à
peu près 60 millions de préservatifs en
vingt ans on a distribué on a fait
partir un train une époque de paris qui
traversait la france vont distribuer des
millions de préservatifs dans les gares
des grandes capitales
enfin dans les grandes villes de france
par dont pour pour pour que les gens
comprennent la seule ville qui avait
refusé à l'époque c'était lyon puisque
michel noir ne voulais pas qu'il ya un
train qui s'arrêtent pour distribuer des
préservatifs dans cette gare on a fait
tourner des avions autour des plages
avec marc et sortez couverts et puis oui
on a sorti ce slogan sortez couverts qui
est devenu qu'est devenu qu'est devenu
quelque chose d'important
j'étais d'indécis d'actions à l'époque
où monsieur bergé mais son prénom me
chabot caire pierre bergé ou pierre
bergé avait gentiment invité un des
derniers qui étaient dans le bois de
boulogne au pré catelan fréchic tout le
monde était là la présence de la
république faisait beaucoup de monde et
puis je suis il y avait une boîte de
nuit qui était une boîte éphémère qui
était qu'était la est bon tout le monde
est un peu parti moi je suis à bout donc
la boîte de nuit m'intéressait donc je
vais dans la boîte de nuit j'ai pris un
verre puis bon il y avait beaucoup
d'hommes et je suis sorti boire d'or et
puis tout d'un coup il ya une file
d'attende comme ça deux jeunes gens qui
s'est formée donc je crois que les
toilettes étaient bloqués à côté je ne
sais pas je regardais est en fait il
s'est tu files d'attentes c'était pour
moi et c'était des 20-40 qui venait me
serrer la louche en bien c'est peut-être
grâce à toi je suis vivant alors
j'arrive à le raconter maintenant sans
avoir la larme à l'oeil même et c'est
pour moi le plus beau compliment qu'on
m'aime comme je n'ai jamais fais tout ce
que je fais depuis 25 ans pour la
prévention du sida
les milliers de fois où j'ai prononcé
sortez couverts en fin d'émission qui
s'adressait aux parents comme aux
enfants les conseils qu'on a pu donner
et on je continue aujourd'hui les
parents qui sont un peu en mousse cahier
avec ça et qui savent pas comment faire
avec leurs ados ils ont qu'à simplement
sans rien dire mettre une boîte de
préservatifs dans la trousse de toilette
garçon ou fille voilà le seul moyen
encore aujourd'hui de ne pas contracter
cette maladie c'est de s'en protéger
avec le préservatif
le message est bien passé merci sortez
couverts tariq on sait qu à l'ena vous
aimez jouer avec les archives un
exercice particulier vous aimez beaucoup
le micro-trottoir des archives poser
exactement les mêmes questions
aujourd'hui qu'auparavant et oui et
cette fois ça donne un micro-trottoir de
1987 il est question capote bien
évidemment mais pas que donc 1987 une
journaliste pose des questions sur le
préservatif sur ce que pensent des
jeunes adultes sur le sida on a posé
nota molde même question avec ludivine
lopez et ça donne ça les sea dogs qu'est
ce que vous en pensez pas en parler ou
pas ouais ouais faut en parler mais moi
je me sens pas trop je le sors je
m'affole pas le sida qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
il faut en parler ou pas oui il faut en
parler pour lever le tabou je pense que
je connais pas plein de choses sur le
sida et je pense avoir plein de choses à
apprendre encore c'est bien d'en parler
mais chose qu'on en parle je ne sais pas
vraiment ce que c'est comme maladie mais
je sais que ça me touche beaucoup de
gens et que c'est fatal le sida ça vous
concerne
bah oui quand tout le monde le sida ça
vous concerne
je pense qu'on est tous concernés à
partir du moment
susceptibles d'être touchés
j'ai eu un cas dans ma famille et du
coup je sais à quel point ça peut être
dur ou porter des préservatifs
non pas du tout c'est un point de vue je
suis totalement opposé à ce pour porter
des préservatifs
bien sûr oui s'il faut oui j'en porte
oui ça m'est jamais arrivé encore et
pourquoi
je vais aussi d'une bonne prévention
contre le sida
oui mais c'est peut-être l'habitude
pourquoi pour éviter notamment
d'attraper cette maladie les autres
geste et mst
pour éviter tout souci de grossesse vous
portez les préservatifs l'amour il doit
y avoir de tout des barrières entre la
chaîne et ce n'est pas une barrière ici
mais avec des préventions en se retenant
un peu puis en essayant de savoir d
d'avoir des connaissances sexuelle sur
sa partenaire on peut très bien préservé
mais sans utiliser la capote sur un
serveur mais là on finit sur une
traîtresse président et n'importe quoi
il est très gentil mais dit n'importe
quoi donc non eh ben on voit que ça a
changé quand même là et est alors
effectivement c'est aussi très important
de se dire que ça protège contre toutes
les ist puisque maintenant on dit plus
un mystère on dit infections
sexuellement transmissibles tout à fait
quand même vous avez hocher de la tête
sur cette fille qui dit je ne sais pas
ce que c'est mais enfin jouer quand je
tâcherai messieurs je réfléchis je sais
pas bien ce que c'est une jeune femme
lui dit je ne sais pas bien ce que
cherche le sida rebonds donc il ya
encore du il ya encore du boulot et pas
mal de chemin parcouru
oui et notamment grâce à vous question
indiscrète pourquoi est ce que vous
n'avez pas le le cycle de luttes contre
lui alors je ne vais jamais me pour être
très franc
parce que j'ai trouvé que comme dans
tout le reste de ma vie
les actes étaient plus importants que
les mots donc je fais je ne porte pas je
connais beaucoup de gens qui le porte et
qui font rien donc je vous préfère agir
en tout cas merci christophe dechavanne
spécial pour votre action
et je rappelle que le sidaction c'est ce
week-end sur les chaînes du groupe
france télévisions notamment un
rendez-vous à suivre et un numéro pour
soutenir c'est le plancton de 110 110
110 et après pour respecter sa promesse
et voilà et qu'est ce qu'on dit à la fin
sortez couverts oui je survive à
découvert oui sortez couverts à écouter
bien sûr amusez vous bien fait les fous
cassé les meubles mais sortez couverts
voilà avant de refermer cette inattendue
notre traditionnel pépite cette semaine
on part dans un paris des confiner le
pari de 1946 où la foule venez profiter
des spectacles de rue des chanteurs et
plus surprenant des fakirs regarder
les mots
et ce en rade
nous pourrions
la chevalier au japon
oui
ce serait bien
baraquin tu t'entraînes mutisme
oui moi
où
elle est où
soit quand même
bah
et moi
l'inattendu c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
on se retrouve mercredi prochain 22
heures sur le canal 27 et toute la
semaine bien sûr sur les réseaux sociaux
que ce soit ceux de l'ina ou ceux de
france info émission préparée avec nos
documentaliste anne delavaux florence us
et merci à elle et merci à vous de votre
présence
[Musique]